the UK economy has got huge potential
and yet the government is failing to
seize that initiative and we see today
with these forecasts from the IMF with
the UK now at the bottom of the league
table for growth both this year and next
the government needs to be doing so much
more to fulfill the potential of the UK
economy when you say so much more what
does that involve many say if you want
to spell growth it should involve at tax
cuts
there's a whole number of things that
the government could be doing Labor's
green Prosperity plan is about working
in partnership with business to see some
of the opportunities and the jobs of the
future that some country is going to be
a global leader in those Industries it
can be Britain but only with a
government that partners with business
did you trust what the IMF is saying
though I mean literally they've got
things wrong in the past I look at the
Ft saying essentially the IMF shows a
poor track record of forecasting
recessions Reuters IMS Crystal economic
Crystal Ballers crack Bloomberg economic
forecasting is really difficult just
after the INF they've got this wrong lot
in the past why would we trust their
predictions today
well if I don't want to look at the
predictions let's look at the facts of
what's happened in terms of UK growth
the average growth for the UK economy
has been just two-thirds under the
conservatives that it was under the last
Labor government and the UK is now the
only major economy to be smaller today
than it was before the covid pandemic
hit that isn't predictions about what is
to come that is the state of the UK
economy after 13 years of conservative
government and just finally are you
supposed the brexit's not part of this
report because you know according to the
ons and others the bank of England
brexit's had a pretty detrimental effect
on our economy over the last couple of
years well the office the budget
responsibility and the bank of England
have been clear that the deal that the
government secured with the European
Union is holding us back as a country is
why labor have committed to actually
making brexit work and fixing some of
the holes in the patchwork brexit deal
because we've got to get our growth
going in our economy we must have our
economy firing on all cylinders and
that's why it would be the absolute
priority of an incoming labor government
to boost growth improve living standards
and have the money that we need to
invest in our Public Services